hey guys so a few people have asked them
to talk about nutrition and so in this
video I'm gonna discuss nutrition so I'm
someone who loves working out mainly for
the love of working out I like watching
action movies and animes and Marvel
films and wondering how I can make
myself faster and stronger and smarter
like my heroes that's what I'm about I
research it and then I bring it to you
on this channel but I'm not someone
who's a competing bodybuilder I'm not a
professional athlete I'm not a cover
model and so I don't need to have a
really strict diet like some YouTube
Fitness guys so yeah I'm not like 6%
body fat by any means but for me that's
fine I think you know it's alright you
can see my my abs and very vascular so
for me that's fine that'll do so I don't
count calories religiously I don't
completely avoid carbs I don't not eat
until 4:00 p.m. but I do generally like
to try and maintain a low body fat
percentage if possible and to build
muscle so I've cut with a system for
eating but I think it's quite good for
those people who want to look and
perform their best but you don't want to
completely change their lifestyle and
maybe eat in a way that's impractical
maybe you'll find it useful for yourself
and maybe you wait let's find out so
there's lots of different eating plans
and as I've discussed if you want these
people who's a professional athlete then
you're probably gonna want to stick to
one of those so some people say that
counting calories is the best way to
lose weight that just means working out
your active metabolic rate how many
calories you burn in a day through both
just being alive and blinking and
breathing but also activity on top of
that and then making sure that you
consume fewer calories than you burn if
you want to lose weight and that you can
seem more calories than you burn if you
want to gain weight then there's those
that count their macros and this
basically means that you work out from
the major food groups carbs proteins and
fats how many of those calories should
be dedicated to each of those things so
if someone is trying to build muscle you
might want to eat more protein and a
lower amount of fats and carbs if you're
trying to stay lean or if you're someone
who's likes the idea of eating more fats
then you might eat more
that's you get the idea then there's
people who will intermittent fast and of
course that means that they're going
through a certain window in their day
where they don't eat and this can vary
drastically some people just don't eat
until 12:00 you know they just wake up
and don't eat breakfast other people any
one meal a day I think that's the
warrior diet then you have people to
completely avoid carbs and stick to
ketogenic diet of just fats and just
proteins then you have people who are
paleo and they only eat things that
aren't processing that we could achieve
in the wild and all this is great
they've all got different positives and
negatives they all work for different
people I'm not going to get into which
one's best or which one you should be
doing like I say the point is that for
me someone who does this for fun and out
of interest and who has quite an active
social life and a wife and good appetite
sticking to any one of those is kind of
not an option for me and some people say
that's lack of discipline actually I
would say I'm pretty disciplined the way
I view it is that if I can't stick to a
diet forever indefinitely then there's
not much point in me sticking to it at
all I'm interested in the long long long
long long term fitness performance etc
and not interested in something that can
only do for a couple of months before I
burn out so what some bodybuilders and
athletes will do once they have finished
their competition and they're kind of
in-between their training cycles is
they'll go into intuitive eating and
this means that they're no longer
counting their calories they're just
getting a rough idea of how many
calories everything no longer tracking
their macros they're just getting a
rough idea of their macros and this is
what you or I might call eating or
eating without being a knob about it so
truth of eating does appeals to me on
the face of it but I do like to have a
little bit more structure and that's why
I call what I do strategic intuitive
eating so it goes like this I count my
calories roughly for the first two meals
of the day so it's kind of like an
intermittent fast in that it's it's a
time schedule thing and then at the end
of the day I relax a little bit more so
that might mean that in the morning I
own eat one bowl of a healthy cereal
some oats
except when I'm bad that is and I have
new girl pillows it might mean that for
lunch that I have a sandwich with tuna
on it and then some eggs and maybe I'll
have a protein shake on top of that and
I'll be all I eat until the evening I'll
I've calculated how many calories it is
any given time at the moment I can seem
something like 800 calories doing this
through the first half of the day and I
know what my AMR is roughly you can only
ever know what it is roughly by the way
there's no way you can completely
accurately know how many calories you
burn and then I know that I've got a lot
of leeway when it comes to the evening
to eat big without gaining lots of
weight so the idea is that during the
first half of the day I find it much
easier to be strict with my diet because
I'm trying to be productive I've got
work to do and planning a complex meal
is complicated and time-consuming
anyways at the same time I'm normally
doing it in a bit of a rush of normal
eating on my own breakfast I eat with my
wife but we kind of would have a sleeps
and they've talked that much and at
lunch I'm just eating quickly whilst I'm
filming what some writing or editing or
coding but then for dinner
that's when my wife's hey we wanna have
a nice meal together that's when we go
out with friends that's when we're
hanging out or you know that's when you
wanna be able to eat that's one you want
might want to have a drink with your
friends and so by being more strict at
the first half of the day for the first
two meals I know that I can eat a
thousand calories if I want to for
dinner and I'm not going over my target
calories so giving me that freedom to be
relaxed and I'm still watching her I'm
still being careful I wouldn't eat them
a massive burger every single night
followed by three Mars bars but I know
that I can be a bit more relaxed at that
time of day when it suits me because
I've been strict at the first part of
the day and to make this work I find a
really good idea is to make sure that
those first two meals are really similar
so you were always sticking to the same
kind of pieces of food again that might
sound pretty boring but like I say the
first emails of day are pretty boring I
love tuna sandwiches there's nothing I
love more than tuna salad so I have no
problem eating that every single day I
love eggs so I have no problem eating a
ton of eggs and I quite like my protein
shake my lean protein shake so I don't
mind having that regularly as well it
doesn't matter to me that that's boring
so I can then be as inventive as I like
in the evening by keeping it the same
you don't have to track your calories
because you know you've tracked it once
it counted once how much you eat
for breakfast and lunch and then you
know that come 5:00 p.m. you're gonna be
on about 800 calories or maybe a
thousand calories however you've worked
out and you've got that large budget to
spend for the rest of your day there are
other aspects to my diet that I try and
keep an eye on of course I'm trying to
build muscle so I want to eat as much
protein as possible the guidelines are
tweet gram of protein per 1 pound of
bodyweight if you want to gain as much
muscle as possible and I've gone into
detail about that on my website and
talked about why that is the case some
people say you don't need too much
protein but I do believe from the
studies that eating more protein is
crucial for building muscle but
personally I find that really hard to
eat that much and I find that as long as
I'm eating a lot of protein I still pack
on muscle so if I just make sure that
I'm always having two protein shakes a
few eggs are so tuna then I pretty much
good to go and if I have a steak for
dinner or something as well
then that's bonus points likewise I do
try and avoid processed foods on the
whole so there's an element of the Paleo
thing in there we all know what's
unhealthy for us we all know that miles
bars we all know that crisps
your chips where you come from probably
unhealthy for us that they are empty
calories that they make us hungry or
that they spike our blood sugar so
there's no benefit to eating sweets and
chocolates and things so you don't have
to be you know a rocket scientist to
know that if you cut out sweets and
things you're probably gonna feel a
little bit more healthy likewise I'm
always trying to make sure I get enough
nutrients and this is a big thing
because one of the big reasons that we
veer from our diet that we snack on we
shouldn't that we crash and don't work
out in the evenings because we don't
have enough energy and one of the big
reasons we often don't have enough
energy is because we're not eating
enough nutrients so I make sure that I
get lots of fruit and veg stock the day
when I detailed my free bed actually I
forgot I have blueberries in the morning
with my wife in the afternoon I have a
banana and for dinner always try and
have two pieces of vegetables and a
piece of fruit for evening and I drink
fruit juice so what are those things
combined plus supplements means I'm
getting a lot of vitamins and minerals
and I will say that you just you feel
more energetic there are lots of
benefits vitamin C is said to help
improve muscle recovery and eating
anything that's going to boost nitric
oxide will mean that your blood flow
will be better or deliver more nutrients
to your muscles I take amino acids and
BC
try and help muscles to recover more to
avoid my muscles being cannibalized when
I'm going low-calorie or the first half
of the day etc I consume creatine which
boosts my energy levels so just by
making sure you're getting lots of this
stuff you just feel your best the
problem is when you're reading about all
these supplements and all these
nutrients and all these great superfoods
is it can seem like you need to eat
everything like this seaweed will make
you die you know not as soon and this
amazing weird fruit will give you a
super I Q and this one will make you
burn a fast and this on weight you build
twice as much muscle right how can I eat
all this stuff
well they worry about that just make
sure you're getting lots of good
nutrients so you feel and perform your
best and that does make a huge
difference and makes it much easier to
stick to the other aspects of your diet
I have a multivitamin as well and in
particular I find that when I have lots
of vitamin C that's something that gives
me way more energy that might just me be
me personally but when I could assume
lots of apple juice and take a vitamin
tablet with a big dose of vitamin C I
feel so much better my mood is so much
better as well which makes sense because
vitamin C boost serotonin I've talked
about cordyceps before on this channel
that's a supplement that helps to fight
a dream of fatigue and 21st century
syndrome as they call it now and I
really like lutein for boosting energy
in the mouth and ensign and I'm a big
fan of creatine as I've said it adds
extra muscle weight with water retention
and it boosts your focus in your IQ in
your energy in the gym all these things
can help on one more omega-3 fatty acid
is absolutely crucial that's one of the
reasons I like to know so much and make
a food fatty acid reduces information it
improves cell membrane permeability so
you can cells can communicate better and
I was reading recently that encourages
myelination of your neurons which could
actually speed up your thoughts so if
that doesn't sound good I don't know
what does so get lots of nutrients do to
summarize what I do is that I eat the
same meals for breakfast and lunch which
I've calculated the calories off and I
keep fairly low and that thing gives me
the freedom to eat more in the evenings
on top of this I make sure I get lots of
protein lots of nutrients and not so
much in terms of the processed foods
ready-made meals Mars bars and chips
it's a pretty simple eating plan but
hopefully it's one that gives
not structured to make sure you're
losing or gaining weight whilst at the
same time not taking up too much of your
time if you'd like to see a complete
breakdown of exactly what I eat every
day pretty much then you can find that
on the bio near comm the link will be
down in the description below so click
that if you're interested so give it a
try if you like and hopefully you'll
find it useful and if not hopefully it's
just raining that you don't have to
choose between being completely strict
and rigid with your diet or being so
relaxed that you just eat whatever there
is an in-between middle ground which is
just to have these loose rules a kind of
strategic intuitive eating thanks ton
for watching guys hope you found it
useful and interesting if you did then
please consider leaving a like it really
helps me out please check me out on
social media down below particularly
Instagram that's where I post most often
I'd love to see you there
let me know in the comments down below
how you eat or 5 milli mistake so we've
got any comments and subscribe this
channel if you'd like to see more like
this more on fitness more on nutrition
on health on brain training productivity
in the trade pics technology
transhumanism that sort of stuff if that
sounds good then I'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
now that I'm grown I eat five dozen eggs
- I'm rock
[Music]
you